so at the beginning of the week we
talked about the horrible dual mass
shooting that took place in Christchurch
New Zealand over the weekend and earlier
in the week I mentioned that New Zealand
seems to be reacting logically to the
mass shooting we heard from the prime
minister Jacinda Arden that they were
going to very quickly tighten up gun
laws we heard a lot of other changes
that very quickly they decided they were
going to make and they're doing it
they're acting very quickly something
the United States hasn't been able to do
after mass shootings or really even at
any point in time and this morning the
announcement was made by the Prime
Minister that all military-style
semi-automatic weapons as well as
high-capacity ammunition magazines and
parts that allow weapons to be modified
in that style are going to be banned as
of 3 p.m. this afternoon
their time very notably the largest
opposition party to the New Zealand
Prime Minister immediately said they
support the measures which is almost
inconceivable in the context of American
polarization around gun safety
regulations part of the reason to put
the regulations in place so quickly is
to prevent people from rushing to buy
and stockpile these weapons before they
are no longer allowed and of course
immediately the gun fetishists in the
United States responded with the
completely I mean it's written on the
wall what their talking points are going
to be completely predictable in every
way some of them include well
military-style is the subjective term
and therefore it's problematic because
it could mean anything yeah I mean
military-style is subjective to a degree
but that doesn't really make it
problematic people in New Zealand will
be able to figure that out and in fact
they've defined two types of firearms as
military-style semi-automatic so number
one semi-automatic firearms capable of
being used with the detachable magazine
holding more than five cartridges and
semiautomatic shotguns capable of being
used also with detachable magazines
holding more than five cartridges so you
could say well that's an arbitrary
definition
a lot of a lot of life is arbitrary I
hate to break it to you they will say if
you ban something it doesn't make it
unobtainable for criminals criminals can
still go and find it well yes of course
that's true but if there are fewer of a
type of firearm legally available there
will be fewer that ultimately make their
way illegally to criminals it's not a
hundred percent but it's something we're
trying to improve the situation they
will say well a lot of those weapons are
already out there that's not going to
change well it's not going to change
100% but New Zealand is going to be
enforcing a buyback of those firearms in
violation that are currently in
circulation will criminals sell theirs
back no of course not all of them will
but they will get many of these firearms
off of the street and then you'll start
here things like you know even if you
take away guns
you're not going to reduce the number of
suicides with guns that take place
because guns are often used in suicides
and if you ban these guns you're not
going to change that people will still
find other ways to commit suicides
number one that's mostly handguns so
this isn't even targeting those types of
firearms and number two it's not true
that suicides don't go down at all when
you restrict guns they go down somewhat
some people who would have committed
suicide with a firearm find another
means to do it
but some don't and importantly that's
not even the focus of these new
regulations and then lastly what about
the cost the cost will be off the charts
it's going to be one to two hundred
million dollars to do the gun buyback
and it's more than affordable for the
country of New Zealand so the take away
that I would be focusing on is that it's
been not even a week it's been six days
since this dual mass shooting in New
Zealand and they're making things happen
they're making things happen in the
United States we couldn't even get
universal background checks passed after
the Sandy Hook shooting with 85 to 90
percent support from Americans for total
and complete universal background checks
it's pathetic it's embarrassing and it's
not going to be
the easiest process for New Zealand
there's going to be issues getting guns
out of circulation the fight around what
exactly constitutes the military-style
semi-automatic maybe contested New
Zealand also only registers 4% of its
guns so even tracking how successful
some of these initiatives are may be
difficult but they're going to figure it
out and importantly they're able to do
things that in the United States we
simply can't because of the gun
fetishists and the NRA and my
perspective on this Pat is that whatever
you think about the specifics of the new
law I can't even imagine American
government moving this quickly and
decisively on an issue never mind
actually achieving any kind of consensus
where the Prime Minister and the primary
opposition party all say yeah this is a
good idea yeah it must be nice to live
in a country where the government
actually represents you and moves
quickly we don't know of course entirely
if this is going to work but after a
mass shooting in 1996 in Australia the
Port Arthur massacre Australia had a
very similar program they did a gun
buyback program and it was very
effective there hasn't been a major mass
shooting since certainly they've had
somewhere four or five six people have
been killed but nothing like the 30-plus
that were killed back in 96
hopefully New Zealand has the same
results we won't know for sure but this
is definitely a step in the right
direction for them yeah and I've seen
the gun fetishists do just extraordinary
statistical and mental gymnastics to
argue that the Australian decision has
not actually worked and the cognitive
dissonance is just utterly utterly
stunning one of today's sponsors is
minds.com mines is an open source social
network platform it's kind of like
YouTube Facebook and Twitter
all in one package except that the goal
of mines is to help create a free and
open Internet where privacy and free
speech are the top priority and to make
sure that content creators are fairly
compensated for their efforts mines
doesn't track you like a lot of other
social networks do and users
minds can earn minds tokens for
interacting with the site such as when
you like dislike or share content or
when you create content yourself by
uploading a photo or video or writing a
blog post then your minds tokens can be
used to boost your content on the site
so that more people will see it
mine's even offers a feature kind of
like patreon where your fans can unlock
your premium content by sending you
minds tokens everything is encrypted for
example minds can't read your private
messages on the platform and like I
mentioned everything is open source
meaning that in the interest of
transparency you can actually see the
code that fuels the site which is
definitely not something that lots of
other social and content sharing
platforms can say mine's sees a lot of
issues with today's most popular social
media platforms especially when it comes
to free speech privacy transparency and
compensating content creators and those
are the problems that they're trying to
solve I encourage you to go check it out
at minds.com there's also a mobile app
and you can actually follow the david
pakman show on mines at minds.com
slash david pakman show I've also put a
link right underneath this video